hi everyone i'm abby schar from abby's
kitchen welcome back to our series
enlightened by intuitive eating
in our last video we discussed principle
number seven of intuitive eating
cope with your emotions without using
food so if you haven't watched that
video
go check it out and of course come back
to watch this one
also a big thank you to alyssa rumsey
intuitive eating dietitian for reviewing
this episode
as always i'll leave links to her social
media and her website so that you guys
can contact her for some one-on-ones
now before we get started i want to flag
that this content may
not be for all of my viewers so feel
free to take what you find
valuable and leave what you don't also
don't forget to follow the intuitive
eating journey along with me
through evelyn tripoli and elise resh's
book which i've linked
below finally my general disclaimer that
the information in this video is for
education
and entertainment purposes only and you
should always speak to your healthcare
provider about your
unique healthcare case let's get into a
reader question
dear abby i really really want to
practice intuitive eating
but i mean residents at college on a
meal plan so
my food options are limited to really
whatever the plan
says or what is offered that day how can
i eat intuitively if i can't choose the
food that is offered
okay so this is a really great question
well of course it would be great if we
were always able to eat exactly
what we felt like or we wanted in the
moment this just
isn't always the case intuitive eating
is all about using your body
and your brain to make decisions so in
this instance where you're limited based
on
what the dining hall is serving if
there's nothing being served that you're
really craving
think instead what can i have that i at
least
like the taste of even if i don't
necessarily
love it and that will keep me feeling
full
satisfied and feeling good in my body
not every single meal is going to be the
most delicious
and satisfying but it still serves a
purpose
to fuel and nourish your body once you
leave residence and
are on a budget and this really applies
to anyone on a budget
you may run into some very similar
struggles for example
it's not feasible for everyone to eat
whatever they're feeling like in the
moment
this could be very likely just too
expensive
in some cases intuitive eating can be a
bit of a privileged thing
if you're struggling to put food on the
table it's probably not feasible to be
overly attentive to your hunger
fullness and satisfaction cues all the
time
and that is totally okay but if you are
in place to do so
there are some steps you can take to
practice some of the different
principles of intuitive eating
even if you are on a budget so intuitive
eating is all about allowing yourself
permission to eat
whatever you want whenever you want but
also knowing that this may not always be
an
option whether that's because the food
is inaccessible financially
seasonally or locally or because you
know
it just won't feel good in your body
right now
when you're on a budget it's about
making the best food decisions that you
can
for you and your body while also
respecting the fact that you can't spend
unlimited cash on the foods that you
want in this case
i encourage you to focus on a few
principles of intuitive eating that
we've already covered
so number one respect your hunger find
foods that feel satisfying in your belly
that taste great and that don't blow
your budget
there are so many satiating filling
foods that are also naturally nutritious
and inexpensive
this may mean that you play around with
cooking more at home
and using more inexpensive foods like
frozen vegetables
grains oatmeal canned foods like beans
maybe things like tomatoes or in season
produce
which of course tends to be cheaper
number two
respect your fullness when on a budget
you may be concerned about food waste
so to avoid this have containers
available so that you can easily store
your leftovers
freeze food that you don't plan on
eating right away or
perhaps give some of the leftover food
to your roommate and your neighbor
and swap number three discover the
satisfaction factor
satisfaction is all about taste and
flavor but also texture
temperature visual appeal smell etc
so for example maybe you're craving beef
which of course we know is more
expensive
so why not make a stir fry with lots of
beans and some grains or rice
and then a smaller amount of meat tossed
throughout
you'll have a really hearty satisfying
meal that satisfies your hunger
stays within budget but also satisfies
that taste for meat
these are just a few things to keep in
mind while on a budget at the end of the
day
you have to focus on what you have time
and energy for
it is possible to eat intuitively even
on a budget
without feeling restricted okay so on
that note
let's move on to the video so in this
video we're gonna be discussing
principle number eight
respect your body if you get anything
out of today's video
i want it to be this if you're at war
with your body
you'll have a really hard time being at
peace with yourself
and with food so even if you soak up all
the information from all of these videos
if you aren't respecting your body then
it will become difficult to fully make
peace with food
when we think about our bodies we openly
accept that
certain things are a result of genetics
hair color
skin color shoe size height these are
all things that are
ultimately beyond our control and that
we are also just naturally born with
we also recognize that we have different
tolerances to food
and may metabolize food differently so
if we can accept that our bodies are so
different from one another
why can't we accept that the size or
shape of our bodies can be two
and of course a massive cause for this
body insecurity can be linked to diet
culture
and the diet industry i mean these days
we're just
bombarded by ads instagram images
and public figures who do not represent
the typical person
as we are all just so different
less than five percent of the population
actually looks like
most of who we're seeing in the media
right now
so it can be really easy to compare
ourselves to others
and create these unrealistic
expectations of what we should look like
not to mention there's the widespread
use of photoshop i mean it's just no
wonder then that people
feel inferior and insecure with their
imperfect bodies
they have to compete with something that
isn't even real
now to make matters worse we have
thousands of wellness
and and fitness influencers out there
many of which
boast that one's body is the sole result
of willpower and determination
that all it would take is properly
following their unique proprietary
program
and you too can have a thin waist
sculpted arms
and a toned butt for life now i have to
say
i absolutely love that more influencers
are being more open
and honest about their fitness and
health journeys with many
including some amazing youtubers like
stephanie buttermore
letting us see some of the unhealthy
undertones of the wellness world
still with facetune and filters we are
still a long
ways away from true body acceptance and
with social media reaching the
fingertips of young children
the social pressure to have the perfect
body
and to look a certain way is starting
before many kids even
hit puberty now with that being said i
could spend this whole video pointing
blame at the diet industry for their
utmost disregard and disrespect for
people
with different bodies or i can help you
get past
their message and respect your body for
the amazing
amazing machine that it is after all
when has
loathing your body really helped you has
dwelling on
tiny imperfections really helped
motivate you to be your healthiest self
chances are no not for any long-lasting
changes at least
it usually just further reinforces a
poor relationship with your body
self and food a negative shame cycle
so many of us have fallen into over and
over again
never seeing the results that we're
looking for so
let's ditch the negative self-talk and
really get to enjoying our bodies at
any stage in our life no matter what
weight or size we are
keep in mind that this is not an easy
journey and you're not going to
magically love every part of your body
after finishing this video it can take
weeks months
or even years to be more accepting of
your body
and even when you are not every day or
every stage will be butterflies and
roses
this is where body respect comes in
because
it's impossible to take care of
something that you hate
or don't respect so instead of thinking
of
loving your body can you instead maybe
work on respecting it
and i'm not saying you have to disregard
your body your health in fact
i'm actually saying the opposite the
goal here is to appreciate your body for
its amazing
abilities and to then respect it by
making decisions
around food movement stress management
etc
that actually take care of your body
just like a friend
or family member or partner you don't
have to love
everything about them in order to show
them love and respect
so respecting your body means to show it
care
and meet its basic needs even if you're
not a complete fan of it
every single day on another note there
are a lot of people who are in
smaller bodies but who are not
physically or mentally healthy
so what i want you to remember is that
regardless of your current size
adopting health-promoting behaviors like
eating nourishing foods
engaging in exercise utilizing positive
coping skills
and getting enough sleep all can improve
your health and well-being
regardless of what you weigh or what
your bmi is so
let's talk about how to respect your
body there are two main things that you
need to respect your body
number one make it comfortable and
number two
provide its basic needs now regardless
of your size
you deserve to have your basic needs met
and to be comfortable
if these basic needs are not met then
you end up
more disconnected from your body your
body starts to distrust you
and you can then feel kind of
distrustful of your body
so here are some examples of basic needs
that your body deserves
my body deserves to be fed on a regular
basis
to be treated with dignity to be dressed
comfortably
in whatever i may choose to be touched
affectionately and with respect
and to move comfortably now in order to
feel comfortable
we need to get a little bit personal
here if you are new to the channel
i'm not afraid to get honest and
personal with you so
i want you to think of the last time
that you bought yourself new clothes
that
made you feel good now in a lot of cases
when people aren't comfortable and
respectful of their body
they tend to wear maybe old clothes that
don't fit them properly
whether those clothes are too big or too
small
but here's the thing buying clothes that
actually fit
our figure can do wonders
so instead of trying to squeeze into a
pair of jeans or wear a sweater that is
like
two times too big i encourage you to
find clothes that fit your
current body that simple act of wearing
clothes that fit your figure
can seriously transform the way that you
see yourself
when you feel comfortable physically it
can help you feel more comfortable
mentally and i understand that there are
financial constraints that
have to be considered here i mean if
you're unable to go buy new clothes
see if clothes can be hemmed or fitted
to fit you better
check out thrift stores which have tons
of really cute clothes at a discounted
price
or do a clothing swap with others who
are around the same size
the key here is to not wait until you
have
achieved your new body to dress yourself
in clothes that feel good
time and time again waiting until you're
at your dream body
is like watching a kettle boil so
live in the now and treat your body with
respect as it is in this very moment
now in addition to being comfortable and
meeting your basic needs
there are also some other things that
you can do to respect your body
one is to change the way you assess your
body
if you're struggling with body image and
trying to repair your relationship with
your body
and food it might be time to put the
scale away
too much emphasis and value is placed on
the earth's gravity
our body weight in my experience those
who are truly happy
and respectful of their body don't weigh
themselves often
i mean the scale really is a tool for a
chronic dieter
it's a game of up and downs with really
no winner
at the end in fact weight and body mass
index bmi have been widely criticized
for their lack of focus on muscle tone
bone mass and other factors that
influence weight
research continues to show that a change
in healthy behaviors
can significantly improve health even if
the weight on the scale
doesn't actually change also get rid of
anything that makes you feel like crap i
mean
for example if you have a pair of jeans
that are too tight
donate them even if you ditch the scale
you may keep trying to put these jeans
on hoping to see
some progress so anything that makes you
feel chronically
bad about your body has really no place
in your intuitive eating journey
next i would say quit the body check
game when you walk into a room
full of people what is the first thing
that you do for most people
you scan the room and you make
observations for a lot of people
especially those who don't have a great
relationship with their body
they might do a quick scan of everybody
else's bodies
and their appearances and compare them
to their own body
you may think to yourself am i the
biggest one here
or how does my body appearance compare
with
others this game that you play is
really really harmful especially if you
start playing comparison
with people you don't even know remember
there are a lot of factors inherent in
someone's body size
and type all people have different needs
and comparing yourself to others is
truly counterproductive
as your needs are more than likely very
different than theirs
you really can't judge a book by its
cover
so try to catch yourself when you find
yourself comparing yourself to others
and put the focus back on yourself next
i would say
don't compromise for the big event if
you have a special event coming up let's
say
a school reunion it's totally normal to
want to look your best
technically it's a subtle form of body
checking like i just mentioned
but we all have a tendency to succumb to
the pressure of
looking good for others for many this
means participating in a quick weight
loss diet
to achieve your desired look fast just
as i've mentioned in previous videos
crash diets rarely result in sustainable
changes
and we risk not only damaging our
relationship with food and mental
well-being
but also our metabolism and overall
health here's the thing to remember
there will always be a special event
there will always be a wedding to attend
an anniversary or a reunion
and if we constantly compromise our
health for a special event
we will be cycling through unhealthy
behaviors all
year round my recommendation
isn't sexy or quick but this is why i
believe you're much better off to invest
the time
in fostering a healthy relationship with
food and your body
rather than focusing on short-term
results
now this doesn't mean you can't look
good for your big event
as i mentioned earlier it's it's often
about how you approach
and respect your body so buy an outfit
that fits your current body
and that you feel really good in don't
buy a dress that is guaranteed to upset
you when you put it on
you know do your hair and makeup nicely
some way that kind of brings you joy
maybe accessorize with fun earrings or
shoes and
own your body the best looking person
in the room is always the person who
feels best in their body
and exudes confidence next let's stop
body bashing this one is very hard to
stop doing because it's considered
normal in our culture to point out the
things that we don't like about
ourselves
and often what we don't like about
others ugh
i have too much cellulite on my thighs
or my arms are so jiggly
i can't stand my double chin ugh my
stomach is so gross
i hate my stretch marks etc i bet it's
a lot this may seem unconventional but
i want you as part of your homework to
count the number of times that you
degrade your body
in a single day you may be shocked at
how many times you
look in the mirror or the window and
make a hurtful comment to yourself
and these comments do hurt especially
when they come from someone as important
in your life as yourself
as you go through your intuitive eating
journey i really encourage you to
surround yourself with
positive uplifting thoughts and people
so instead of focusing on parts of your
body that you don't like
i want you to find what you do like
about yourself
or at the very least are indifferent
about
start simple and go from there for
example
maybe you really like your eye color
continue to remind yourself of that
because these small positive beliefs can
help transform your overall appraisal of
yourself over time
every time you catch yourself being
negative about your body
replace it with a kind and compassionate
statement
so here are some examples oh my eyes
look so saggy
can become i really like my hair today
my thighs are too big can become my
arms are so strong they're strong enough
to pick up my kids
those are just two simple examples but
if you have a hard time
saying things that you like about your
body and that's totally normal and part
of this growing process
i want you to phrase your negative
comment in a respectful
practical way so for example the i hate
the cellulite on my legs
could become i'm really fortunate that i
have strong legs
that move my body around or i'm so out
of shape it's disgusting
can become my body got me to work today
played with my kids and finished all of
the chores in the house
so yeah it was hard to exercise today
but there is always tomorrow
now finally i want you to stop the body
shaming with yourself
and with your friends don't allow
yourself to participate into grading
comments about yourself
or anyone else now let's talk about
respecting
body diversity as a society we celebrate
diversity in
many forms yet we still really struggle
with
body size diversity just like some
people
are tall and some are short some people
have big feet some people have small
feet
some people are in smaller bodies
naturally and some people are naturally
in bigger bodies
we all come in different shapes and
sizes yet we tend to be critical of
ourselves if we don't look
a certain way this is what is taught to
us by diet culture
as i mentioned earlier there are so many
things that contribute to body sizes
that are different
the main one being genetics we need to
stop assuming that
every person is in a larger body because
they're doing something
wrong this is a conversation that
deserves more time but
prejudice against larger bodies is a
massive
issue in our society and this extends
beyond the social world
into the medical field in fact research
has shown that weight stigma that is
discrimination or
stereotyping of someone based on the
size of their body
has a bigger impact on our overall
health than just the food that we eat
weight stigma contributes to poor health
for many reasons
for example people in larger bodies
often have experiences of going to
doctors
and being shamed for their weight which
can then lead them to preventing or
delaying
seeking out medical care too often some
medical professionals
ignore a person's chief complaint and
zone in
solely on weight as the root cause so
you may have come to see your doctor for
an earache
and yet the recommendation somehow
becomes to lose weight
that is unacceptable as healthcare
professionals
we have a duty to treat illness
regardless of size
and as humans we have a duty to treat
everybody with equal respect
if you're struggling with this there are
resources available to search for a
physician who doesn't promote this
weight normative care and you can search
at hazecommunity.com
to find one of those positions finally i
want you to say
goodbye to the fantasy now this may be
really hard to do and
may take a long time to accept but a key
step in respecting your body is coming
to terms with the idea
that you may not lose the amount of
weight
or be the small size that you really
really want to be
it's hard for people to hear but your
body just may not be designed to be
that particular size or that particular
weight that you really want to be
you might not be meant to be the size
that you were when you were 20 years old
your set point may simply be set at a
higher notch
than your friends unfortunately not
coming to terms with this can
really interfere with our satisfaction
with our life
in many cases focusing on modifiable
behaviors like
eating movement and stress reduction can
help to improve
health even if the size of your body
doesn't change that much
it may take time to mourn the loss of
your dream body
but i really want you to take a second
to appreciate
the new opportunities that you have in
front of you
think about the price that you've
already paid just trying to get this
body
time energy emotions money
health by saying goodbye to the fantasy
and finding respect for the body that
you do have
you're opening the door to living a more
peaceful happy life
and an opportunity to better engage in
self-care
again i want to emphasize that i'm not
saying that losing weight
is being disrespectful to your body in
fact by respecting your body
you may be engaging more in healthy
eating practices
gentle movement better stress management
better sleep etc
all of which may cause you to lose
weight
i'm just saying in order to make changes
in your life this all needs to come from
a place of respecting your body
not from a place of hating it now for
your homework this week
i want you to find two things that you
like about your body or at least are
very neutral about
and whenever you're about to criticize
your body i want you to reframe it
and remind yourself of the things that
you really do like
remember these things take time and you
don't want to rush the process
but even little shifts can add up over
time
again continue to work on all of these
steps throughout your intuitive eating
journey
and stay tuned for our next video on
principle number nine
exercise feel the difference so folks on
that note that is all for today
don't forget to give me the thumbs up if
you like this video
leave me a comment below if you have any
questions that you want me to
answer in an upcoming episode of
enlightened by intuitive eating
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye